BGM loud?
I couldn't tell.
Got infected by the game's bad audio mixing.
Confirm she hates us now!
Hello everybody, welcome back to Deadly Premonition.
Finally, finally, finally, finally.
I said, can you pass the sugar?
Whoa, road!
What the heck?
Thank you so much for the hug, Supa!
We can only hear the music!
Also, I finished the traveling part of my move!
But it's some hotel living until I can get into an
apartment.
Oh, that's tough!
You got this though!
You got this!
Congrats on getting through the travel part!
That's always... That's always rough.
What?
Please pick up, ma'am!
I can't hear you!
How could you not hear me with my perfect audio balancing?
10 out of 10 bit though no it's thank you hello amito and i
boo's like you after you mentioned the minecraft vinyl
yesterday i finally got to spinning it up this morning and
it's so nice thank you for reminding me of it wait combo i
was also listening to it this morning we were twinning we
were twinning it's so nice right yeah
twinin twinin twinin we are back deadly premonition last
time i feel like we ended off on like i mean it's always
crazy i would love to stay and watch but i have to sleep
late however the stream involved will no doubt be great so
says mr stewart good night lollipop delicious thank you
thank you thank you
yo me though how does you do i'm doing amazing Amazing.
I hope you guys are also...
I got quite a bit done today.
So I'm feeling good.
Probably not things that I needed to work on.
But can you do a recap of where we left off?
Yes!
Where we left off was Mr. Stewart called us to his
establishment.
The game has been crazy, but also it's about to start
escalating a lot.
What?
um we went to mr stewart's establishment and he was like hey
by the way um not that i am you know i don't i nobody else
in this town he didn't fart sorry i did that with my mouth
it just sounded really bad when i heard when i i'm actually
a twin myself twin he's rise up no way I mean, maybe he did
fart.
So true.
Maybe he did.
Okay, good.
I was confused.
Oh, so sorry.
Yes, so sorry.
He didn't.
He didn't do that.
He was like, hey, by the way, in this town, nobody remembers
but me.
He has.
like a problem you know we don't know we don't we just
really get sorry I feel like I'm six years old right now he
nobody else remembers but him but there was a true raincoat
killer and there was a true raincoat killer and of course
nobody knows but him um the government wiped it wiped the
story off the map nobody knows about this yeah the og
raincoat killer yeah and um quite honestly that's all i
remember leaving awkward parties and going home to watch the
peak vtuber play peak yeah we're already start beginning so
strong tonight so says mr too far.
No!
Hello, Minto.
My bestie asked me to be his best of man.
Whoa, let's go, Monty.
That's so cool.
Minto!
Cyber Fishing!
Hope you're doing well.
Are you excited for Off-Kai so soon?
I'm very nervous for Off-Kai so soon.
Off-Kai so soon means that Legends Anu is so soon and I'm so
nervous.
the first one who smelt it dealt it so says mr.
Stewart thank you thank you for the pink thank you thank you
deadly premonition I too am having a premonition of a live
show in one month in New York City starring Minto and
friends skyline serenity get your tickets now oh did you
just pin your own message yeah actually Shachi was just
announced as a guest too so I'm excited I'm so excited I
didn't know he could do that either I feel a little like
violated I feel a little scared the guest list is stacked
yeah I was I was really happy I got to sing with her during
Doki's Doki Doki Doki rewind so
Yeah, so, I'm excited, I'm excited to, to, for everything
for Legends of New and Skyline Serenade, yes, yes, yes.
Waiting for streaming tickets, there should be, there should
be, there should be, there should should be, mm-hmm.
But yeah, it's rewind time, rewind time.
Jay!
Thank you!
For such an amazing performance at Smash, it was my first
ever convention and concert!
Hope you will like the key charms and the Ectoplasm perfume!
Itself is my gift to you.
Wait, I can't wait to get those.
Thank you!
Thank you for coming to Australia.
Thank you, Jay!
Thank you, thank you, thank you for the Hakazupa!
Thanks for coming to see us.
I had so much fun.
I hope next time I can go to...
Australia con for real because Vicky and Phoebe they were
like having the times of their lives they were like they
were like we gotta get you here they were loving it they
were like we don't want to leave I was like is it that good
is it that great I guess so maybe so many cons wow I know
right oh we're worldwide worldwide everything's upside down
I know when I was when I was meeting with everybody
everybody was doing hands-to-hands so talented so talented
mr.
worldwide world wide minky minky worldwide wait I just saw
that mr.
worldwide himself pitbull just broke the Guinness world
record for the most people gathered wearing bald caps
The most people gathered wearing bald caps together.
Remember when World Records used to be like, I don't know,
did anybody else ever own the Guinness Book of World Records
like book?
You know, like a physical book?
That was, I had one.
I had one.
And I always would like look through it and be like, oh my
gosh.
These are like the most impressive things ever.
This is a big coffee table book.
Says you.
I used to read it.
I used to flip through it and be like, one day.
Actually, I don't even know if I said one day.
I would just be so impressed.
I would just go through and be like, wow.
World's biggest foot.
And finally back in QLD after the concert yesterday.
Thanks for coming to Australia.
It was my first concert ever.
My first time doing Calls Chants and Wota Gang.
I'll remember it forever.
See, see.
Thank you.
I'm so glad.
Look, everybody, like, you know, it was my actual first time
doing anything in Australia as well.
And so I know that there are many Wota and fans and stuff in
Australia.
But at the same time, since it's a new place for us, it was
like...
You know, it's so, it's, it's nerd, you're nervous.
Like, is, I was, is anybody going to come to the meeting
greets?
Guys, is anybody going to go to the concert, to the panel,
or anybody, people know the calls?
So it was really, really, it was really, really awesome
that, you know, it does feel almost like we're worldwide for
real.
Which world record would you like to beat one day, Minky?
So many longtime fans getting the first chance to see y'all.
It felt really, really nice.
It felt so good.
Yeah.
My record would be...
I want something like a squirrel, like most carrots shoved
in my mouth.
Baby carrots.
Most of baby carrots in my mouth.
You need to start practicing.
I do every day.
I love carrots.
We should use Off-Kai to break the bald cap world record.
You know, though, the Guinness Book of World Records, I
don't like it anymore.
And I'll tell you why.
Because you have to pay.
To get the record.
And so I would have to call them up and be like, hey, you
know that Pitbull World Record you just beat?
I now have a new one.
And then be like, all right.
Pay up.
I'd be like, okay, fine.
What do you mean?
If I actually have the world's largest foot, I can't just be
in the book.
Because of what?
I posted to Reddit and say, look at my huge foot.
I have the world's largest foot.
It's two feet long.
and and and then the Guinness Book of World Records would be
like no you don't because you didn't pay us I don't even
know how much it is it's 10k it's heckin money that's a lot
no
way 10k USD so to post my biggest foot ever on spending time
I'm on R slash Bigfoot.
If I post my Bigfoot on Reddit, I would be expecting 10K
Buckeyeoos because apparently it's worth that much.
I do wonder what kind of like Guinness World Record VTubers
could break though.
It's something silly, I don't know.
Like, most iPad screens in the same room.
But I feel like any kindergarten would beat that.
I could buy $10,000, $1 bills with that.
Exactly!
You have much better uses of your cash.
Funds for the Minto Foot Fund or whatever.
It was hypothetical.
Isn't there a record held by a hollow VTuber?
Oh, maybe.
Probably, like, a CCB thing, right?
Or, I don't know.
But what about indie VTubers?
Like, I want, like, a gathering.
Like, something of a gathering of VTuber.
Botans has a world record.
Oh, really?
You should get the world's cutest ghost award.
Most cup noodles in one place.
World's largest packet ramen.
Botan had 30k cup noodles used to spell something out.
Holy moly.
Wait, that's kind of crazy.
That's actually kind of crazy.
They spelled the word with the noodles.
That's so funny.
Is there an MGS record?
I think the longest cutscene belongs to Metal Gear, no?
Doesn't the longest cutscene belong to Metal Gear?
So probably, it's just four, yeah.
My, I've been putting together my, I'm almost done putting
together my Metal Gear cabinet of my trinkets and stuff.
And I've had to, my, my bottom, shelf used to be Minto and I
had to take all the Minto things out because I had to have
too much I have too much Metal Gear so now I need a new
place for my Minto display sadly I don't think I need any
more Metal Gear stuff I think I'm good I think I'm okay
Minto discarded.
No!
Never, never.
I'm just gonna find a new place.
Yeah, I might have to get a new...
Might have to get a new shelf or something.
But will that really stop you?
Honestly?
I mean...
It would depend on what they release.
There is a Master Collection 2 coming out, and the
pre-orders look mighty good.
shiny i'm not gonna lie i'm a sucker for any yoji shinkawa
stuff anything with his artwork i'm like i'm gonna eat it up
i'm gonna eat it up i'm gonna eat it up but i think for like
old merch i'm only missing a few things that i want and the
largest packet of noodles according to guinness is held by
indo foods for 340 centimeter by 235 centimeter by 47 packet
of new rules.
That's the largest packet of new rules.
Did you see the Yodichi Kawa artwork for the new Ghost in
the Shell?
I did!
Zone of the Ender Street win!
Oh my gosh, Kamakura's.
It's so funny that you actually mentioned that because I was
unpacking my games earlier and I saw Zone of the Enders and
I was like, hmm.
Maybe I'll play that like next month.
Probably after Off-Kai.
and stuff.
I will...
So, actually, quite soon, Son of the Enders will happen.
Stream Boktai?
What am I going to stream outside?
Miss Maiden and Phantom, we are so happy for your successes.
Success, since your efforts are genuine and honest, we can't
wait to see you in concerts.
So says, Mr. Stewart.
Thank you, Nicholas!
I just looked on their website and think there is a free
process.
It just takes ages.
But you can pay to speed up the process.
But does not guarantee your attempt will be successful.
And no refunds.
That's horrible.
It's horrible.
Oh, how many do?
Oh, hiyao!
Gozaiimasu!
Oh, hio gozaiimasu!
The free...
It's literally pay to win.
Maybe.
I can't imagine being like, oh my gosh, I'm going to pay
$10,000.
Do you have a T-Rex?
To pay $10,000 to apply for the Guinness Book of World
Records, and then somebody does it before you.
It's crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
Pay to win minus winning.
Pay to gotcha.
What are the rates even?
See that, Zach?
Minto.
In the coffin.
Deadly Prevanition!
By the way, Minto, do you have a favorite La Bulbul or what
do you want?
I don't know.
I like...
I don't have a favorite.
I just see...
I like the past.
Deli ones.
Maybe.
Record for most money spent on submitting records.
Yeah, shall we?
It's been a while since we've done Deadly Permission, shall
we?
Get back into it.
I'm gonna have to remember how to play for real.
Do people still buy Lebovoys?
I thought they bought those dumplings now.
I have no idea.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Am I- am I- am I streaming?
Am I- oh!
I think I'm back?
I'm thinking back?
We're back?
I think we're back?
I'm sorry about that.
Oh!
Hopefully...
Hopefully it...
It um...
cooperates today.
I'm really hoping that my basically I don't have fiber
internet anymore.
I'm so sad.
I'm so, so sad.
But hopefully it comes to me soon-ish.
Yeah.
Hopefully, hopefully.
It does stink.
It really does.
thing my streams have been acting funky lately i think it's
me this time though truly
no fiber deficiency yeah i gotta eat more fiber
kiwi skin is good for fiber i love kiwi i'm stuck with cable
internet dog no but hopefully i can get hopefully i can get
fiber sooner rather than later.
I've been, I've been, I've, I'm on, I'm on like sign up
lists and stuff.
I'm on sign up lists for, if it, if it comes to my area.
Let's all get dial-ups.
So true!
Been having a few issues on other streams along.
Too many to just be me, them, or the streamer.
You guys are just trying to make me feel better, maybe.
you guys are just trying to make me feel better yeah do do
sauce upload speed
wee just pay them to have them put down the cables easy yeah
i'll say can you come here right now i'll pay you 10k
guinness world record bucks i'll pay you 10k robux to to
play down the cables for internet
Guinness dollars
How much would okay somebody has to know how much would ten
thousand row bucks be Like an equivalent of a US dollars?
10,000 row bucks because I feel like with a row bucks like
things are probably like a hundred row bucks or something.
I don't know.
I don't know the currency exchange at all.
I think it's $100.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Robux is stronger than the dollar right now.
10,000 Robux is 100 USD.
700 rupees.
okay shall we continue deadly premonition exciting I
explained a little bit earlier episode 3 hidden memories I'm
rich and you guys we can we can afford we can afford we can
afford Guinness Book of World Records record amount and also
rent let's go We got this.
We got this.
So many robux.
Yes, perfect.
So you want to find out everything there is to know about
Diane?
It's in York.
Nick is leading the bar.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
This lady.
She's still alive.
Stop right there, Nick.
You're under arrest for the attempted murder of Diane.
And he's in the cell still.
You saved my life.
No need to thank me for that.
I'm pretty useless.
Then we fumbled hard.
I couldn't save Diane.
No talk from Mr. Stewart?
Yeah, Nick is going crazy in there.
He's like, meow, meow, meow!
And then they cut to Center Sandwich.
So we are.
We are, we are outside Mr. Stewart's home.
if you call it that whatever fucked up torture method is in
there he won't let you he won't let you use the bathroom
unless you solve his riddles it's so messed up fumble that
could be seen from space truly his mind palace I'm noticing
look at the camera it follows you kind of maybe it doesn't
maybe I was giving it too much credit.
He's...
So let's just follow the arrow.
I can't remember what we're doing.
He said, go somewhere.
Okay, I have my...
I have my driving.
Wait, this car is...
Wait.
This car is at 20%.
I can't remember where I would be on the screen.
Is here good?
How much for the Sinner Sandwich cooking stream?
I slap.
I slap together a bunch of ingredients.
Sinner Sandwich.
Stream over.
I take a bite.
If ye would go to pee, you must solve my riddles three.
I meant to mention this last time, but the jail cells have
door handles on the inside.
No!
Oh, guys, the license plate says VidGames.
This is our ride.
Only gamers drive this.
Wait, I want a license plate that says VidGames.
That's awesome.
Oh, and it's good.
It's good.
Okay, hold on.
Let me remember how to break.
Okay.
Reverse.
Break.
We don't need a break.
Boost.
Yes.
Let's go to wherever we're going.
Oh.
Brink.
Accelerate.
Why is this?
This one's really zippy.
This one's very zippy.
Oh, oh gosh.
But we're still at 100%.
Okay.
Excuse me, sir.
May I use your bathroom?
Yeah, but you have to go through my nexus first.
This car, oh my gosh, you guys, I'm barely touching the...
Out of the way!
I can't control this thing!
You gotta leave!
This thing is rogue!
Ah!
Sorry.
we're fine everything's okay oh let's talk anyway zach
even emily could be targeted next i can't rule that out all
the more reasons to catch the raincoat killer asap very true
that means working closely together you and me work out the
emily situation later oh yeah that's right we're i mean i'm
not interested in emily because she's female female just
saying she's interesting you know as in interesting why
isn't why am i lagging so bad she reminds me of something i
used to feel that's all something like back when i first met
you you know that feeling we all used to feel back when we
were kids what's that feeling safe while also feeling the
need to protect that kind of feeling are you like is she
your mom who made me feel that back then your mom anyways
we're getting closer one step time to cracking this case oh
yeah i have a feeling it's going to get tough how's the
audio by the way i just turned it up a little bit but let me
know if i need to turn it up even more
out of the way richard quint wait oh it's in disguise guys
What is happening?
What is going on?
Why do I have to leave him?
He looked so comfortable and polite.
This is a hidoi.
Hidoi.
Okidoki.
He's a wizard.
Maho-tokai.
Where were we going?
Telepermanation, Mystery of the Druids collab.
Quint is doing the Lowry floating pose.
Oh wait.
Hmm?
Nothing.
Just my imagination.
We're back at the Sheriff's Department.
Oh no.
Guys be prepared, we'll never hear them.
Can there really be doctrines here that the FBI doesn't hang
out?
What do you think, Zach?
Just rely on the subtitles.
Letting the autopilot take care of it while I get some air.
So true.
I don't really want to go back to Zach.
York, I told you.
That's nothing more than local folklore.
Harry said that he was there.
The Raincoat Killer is a phantom made up to scare children
long ago.
I can't believe you fell for that from Harry, of all people.
I agree with George.
Harry likes to play with people.
Play with their minds, too.
Oh, he's a freakazoid.
George.
Emily.
Of course I don't believe him.
Sticks up his finger.
I'm actually...
George.
Please don't mind if I at least try to confirm that he's
wrong, will you?
Hmm.
Well then, can you look for the files by yourself?
I'm still looking for Thomas.
Thomas!
Well, Emily.
Open the filing room for him.
Doesn't look like you're looking for Thomas.
Looks like you're sitting at your desk.
What's happening?
I can't move.
You're here too, Zack.
What?
This might mean we're getting warmer to what we need.
The famous folklore about the floating driver.
But we were just...
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
How do I shoot again?
There we go.
We were just...
Inside!
Amazing.
Thank you.
Oh.
Is he dead?
No?
Oh, they're coming.
Amazing.
Dang, they're tough now.
What the heck?
Is he still alive?
Oh my god.
Bullseye.
Great.
Can't kill me.
Don't want to die.
They're tanky!
What the heck?
Why are they so tanky?
So...
Are we suddenly in a dungeon?
Everything was fine two seconds ago.
Are we in the police station?
Where are we?
It's looking even worse in here than usual, I'd say.
Yenwei, thank you.
If Zombo tries to grab at your tongue, let them cook and see
where they're going with it.
My tongue?
Crazy aim.
Cheggie, I have questions for you.
I'm confused by your post.
Huh?
Oh.
We're profiling?
He's breathing?
He's looking at things, I think?
He's emptying the garbage?
He's running away?
I have to ask, does that ruin the bitrate of the stream?
It does?
That's so funny.
Sorry.
A bit.
Okay.
I guess I'll just check all of these.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, I'll take that, yeah.
Thank you.
Baby Cori, thank you so much for the fun.
Do-do-do.
Oh, so where?
Oh, oh,
oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
That's what I need to do, but I'm doing a really poor job at
it.
Yes, a shot.
Great.
Is that it?
That was horrendous.
Yeah, some warrants.
Morning shots, exactly.
I was like, hey, mister, you don't want to miss with this.
Oh.
Ah!
Looks too conspicuous.
Someone remove something.
You got broken safe.
Into my clues.
We'll profile.
We just did.
So we'll do it after we get a second.
hint or something.
Alright, nice.
Very good.
Guessing there's nothing else here.
No one back here.
There is a door.
Oh, okay.
We can go through here.
And then there was one down here.
She skipped the profiling.
It's fine!
Like I said, we'll do it the second time.
anyway oh save room nice uh save yeah is this gonna cost me
oh i i actually earned money i'm starting the original mgs
on ps1 today after you got me into the series with delta got
any tips for me oh the vendors have so much fun have so much
fun they pay you to save let's see how my sanity my food and
my sanity seem pretty good so we don't need to we don't need
to take a little nap or anything do we need to change am i
stinky looks almost brand new no problem it'll take a
million hours for it to get clean almost brand new.
I thought I got, I thought I sent this one to get clean, no?
Mundai Ness.
All right, nice.
Infinity Hours.
That's what I'm saying.
All right, let's go through this dang dungeon that appeared
out of literal no where oh my gosh don't walk i got another
gun but i'm gonna hold off for music there's a lot of guys
in here though i'm just gonna snipe them for now don't
notice me i'm still trying to line up my there so tanky so
freaking tanky Bullseye.
Bullseye.
Yes.
Ah!
Uh.
Oh my god.
Run.
Oh, there's one.
There's another guy down here, though.
Oh my god.
Great.
Bullseye.
Amazing.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, there's two more guys down there.
Scary.
Oh, that was scary.
Okay.
I like to snipe them, because otherwise they'll come at me.
Oh, I have the shotgun!
That's right.
And my katana.
More shotgun!
Yeah, baby.
Where's my...
It's so hard to light up.
Hello?
Will I even...
Oh.
Let's go close.
So close.
Am I too far?
Hoomst.
Her?
Ah!
The floor!
Oh my god.
Yes.
I feel like they're gonna keep coming.
They're gonna keep coming.
I feel like, okay, I gotta snipe these guys if I wanna run
past.
No!
Floor guy.
Ah, floor, floor guy.
Yeah, I don't think I can snipe them.
They're too far.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, please.
No.
Zach!
Zach, give me a sniper stat!
Give me a sniper rifle,
Oh, there he is.
We've sped up the process.
Yes.
Oh, no, please stop!
Amazing.
I know.
Thank you.
Is he gonna...
Is he gonna dis...
Oh, gosh.
Another one.
Nice shot.
Great.
Amazing.
I...
There's a PSG-1 and the B-1 armor.
Ah!
No!
Oh my god.
Amazing.
All right, let's run.
Yee!
Yeah, it triggers every time he get close.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm so dead.
Wait, I'm so dead right now.
Oh my god.
Great.
Yes.
Uh, no, no, ew.
Shotgun.
Oh, double kill!
Triple kill?
Triple kill, baby!
Let's go!
Holy cow!
How did we even manage to stop doing that?
Oh, I probably just could have gone back to the...
my other one but um reload okay well that sucked i can't
leave now why not york buddy york my pal where are we going
where is there to go there's nowhere to go we going where
are we headed gosh sometimes lining up with their heads is
so annoying but they drop shotgun shells kind of i think
it's an infinite spawn unfortunately otherwise i think it
would have died by now yes
unless another oh is it just you no oh uh i'm running let's
ignore that let's ignore everything farming money too true
oh shoot okay there's a handful of guys in here
You're fast.
Don't kill you or kill you?
How did I kill that other guy in the back?
I don't know.
Amazing thumbnail.
Thank you very much.
Nice.
My honor.
I don't want to die.
Red seed!
Hmm?
Wait, what?
Red seed.
Ta-da!
I think it's really funny that I put on a hot dog suit, and
it very much confuses people.
There's always somebody who's like, why does she wear it?
Okay, he snuck.
in he left his seed just dripping it all over the place
dropping everywhere
1969 nice hot dog why oh we still don't have all the answers
whatever that sound is sounds like something's dragging okay
the smirk he's too cool but also Also, that candy jar.
It doesn't matter if we're in the evil realm or not.
Candy reigns supreme.
Don't want to die.
The nightmare dimension has sweets.
Yeah, baby!
Delish!
Oh, uh, where?
Oh, oh, there?
Wait a second.
Ah!
Oh, I did a loop.
I think.
Oh, my god.
I didn't want to use...
But it's okay.
We'll take that.
Oh, never mind.
We won't take that.
We'll put that in our toolbox.
Be careful of floor, but...
Now it's floor ladies.
Which...
Ladies, ladies, ladies.
Floor.
ladies ladies ladies this this guy even if he were taken oh
it's right next to the door okay yes great yes
run run run even if he wasn't taken or even if he wasn't
taken he's too stupid to know do you see me oh yes you do
You're doing...
You're doing the conga for me.
Amazing.
Great.
Little conga line.
Wait, who else is seeing me?
Ah, there's too many guys!
Ah!
I want my katana.
Oh my...
No!
Maybe I can get both of them if I line them up.
well come here come nice oh you're still oh you're both
still alive great oh no they
shot yeah amazing nice double dudes one minky dog with a
membu cola please wait this wasn't a maid cafe a minute ago
where are Oh no, it's another...
Hopefully not unlimited.
Oh, yes.
Hopefully limited.
Great.
Hopefully...
Oh, it was limited, it was limited.
Very good, very good.
Oh, no, that's not what I meant to press.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
I cannot believe my katana broke!
It's so sad.
thing ever.
Holy.
The fast ones are so scary.
Oh,
you too?
Oh my god, wait, he's gonna shoot me.
No, don't shoot!
My hands are up!
Officer!
Officer, you missed.
I'm trying, I'm trying to let you die, buddy.
Oh, don't, don't shoot.
Wait, it's, oh gosh.
that was that was freaky it was a shoddy replica not true
japanese steel you're so right I should have known oh yes
this is because your sword was a tool of justice and you
denied it its purpose that's so not true also that wasn't
even my sword anyway yeah
don't want to die
Nice ammo.
Ammo's always a treat.
We love ammo.
I guess it doesn't hurt to take this, huh?
Unless it's a trap.
Is it a trap?
It's more air?
Wait, I thought it was a health kit.
Let's dance.
I can't wait to play Rising again.
But also I'm scared to play because I feel I should I played
it on easy the first time I played because I am so bad with
Perry and I'm afraid that I will continue to be bad with
Perry well if that isn't saucy me though you're a gamer now
maybe I got ice cream good idea man good idea Oh, come on!
Oh,
get up!
Get up, York!
Oh my god.
Go, go.
Run this way.
Ah!
Get the money.
And leave.
Leave.
Behind you.
Oh, shoot.
I just got a knife.
No, I need to go back in there!
No, I need to go back in there.
Whatever.
Oh, no!
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Dang it.
Okay, let's just keep the shotgun on us.
Okay, man.
You're doing too much.
Hello?
Distracted by delicious ice cream.
You have five DMC games under your belt.
I believe you'll be able to play revenge on even hard I
don't know Henry you you give me so much so much credit I
love invincibility frames and cutscenes right all right so
we definitely need to be in here ice cream okay oh that was
close one oh
shoot that's not what I meant to do I keep pressing the
wrong button.
I'm getting all flustered now.
Right in the pee-pee.
Ice cream!
Okay.
Sound like he said, fuck you.
Below the beltline is crazy.
It's a live or dead situation, okay?
I was scared.
I think there's more guys even.
Where, though?
Oh, oh, there it is.
Okay, maybe we're safe now.
Nope.
Let's grab the thing.
Uh, oh, okay, just kidding.
Another one.
Do do do do.
Oh my gosh.
The direction was...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, zombie noises, not traumatized generations.
Please!
Can I check this?
Oh, observe, observe.
We'll just let the cutscene save us.
I parried by flicking the stick toward every time I
attacked.
Typhoon was incredibly easy.
No way.
Dry drops of water.
I'm profiling.
Ignore the zombie.
Can you hear him?
Are we going to be able to hear him while we're profiling?
Excuse me.
I got to light one up while I think.
What if he, like, comes out over to me and I put it out on
his forehead?
That'd be sick.
Okay.
all right we're dropping the seeds we're dropping the seeds
yeah 1969 baby just kidding oh he's like taking the whole
thing Zach looks like we need to continue our search for the
documents why is he
Goodness gracious, you're just terrifying.
George, I'll get right to the point.
It looks like someone else has just removed the documents
I'm looking for.
No way.
Huh?
Removed?
The cabinet looks like it had been forced open.
That's impossible.
No one could break into there.
No, Emily.
There is one person.
can access that room at any time Thomas you don't mean
Thomas it's too early to speculate and profiling is my job
wait no way more importantly Emily could you get me a coffee
a fresh one if possible coffee at a time like this why
that's also not her job Emily please this is very important
some coffee and bring some milk on the side.
You know something, don't you?
We gotta read our coffee.
We gotta read what's in there.
So tell me what you know.
Tell me what you know, Zach.
Come on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
He downed it.
Sound like.
The big fish are coming is that what that cup said i sure
hope so is this does it say tea like thomas ah zach this is
amazing even the taste of her coffee is thrilling to say the
least what no nothing everybody can hear you this isn't the
cup that thomas always uses for me is it i'm sorry about
that too i just use the cup that was nearby.
You have a problem with that?
He's such a duck case.
It's so funny, my dear Emily.
Well, okay, taste aside.
This cup certainly is perfect.
Oh, the fish are biting at the falls.
Oh, the fish are biting at Velvet Falls.
Wait, that's our clue?
George, Emily, we're going to Velvet Falls.
There's something waiting for us there.
I can feel it.
York, are you joking?
You're trusting your cup?
No, Emily.
George has had such a change of heart.
It's kind of insane.
In feng shui, a waterfall is known to be a source of power.
That's true.
Water is the source of power.
Even if we find nothing there, I'm sure it will give us some
power.
Thanks for the vote of confidence, George.
Don't forget to bring a fishing rod.
The fish are biting there.
I'll go get it.
Fishing?
Are you too serious?
Wait, do I actually get the fish?
George has drunk the Kool-Aid.
Not a single sane person is left in this town except Emily.
Oh my gosh.
Hidden memories.
Boom.
Yeah!
Give me my daily allowance, thank you.
If he can't trust his cup, then who can't Can he trust?
Yes.
Oh.
Is it really going to be Thomas?
Or is Thomas also, for some reason, trying to figure out the
raincoat killer for some reason?
Episode 3, 17, new raincoat killer.
Like, what if Thomas is not as...
Hope we can catch a big one.
What if Thomas is not as, like, you know, goofy guy that we
think, and he's actually also trying to figure out the...
Oh my god!
It's happening!
We're finally fishing!
Oh!
With life is beautiful in the background, this might be...
greatest day of my afterlife!
It's happening!
Fishing rod bait worm Wait for the right time to get a big
hit but if your line breaks you will lose one bait so be
careful This song is so good
you guys oh my gosh i was just about to think i need i'm all
about vinyls lately huh i was gonna say i need this
soundtrack on vinyl but i discovered there is a switch
collector's edition of this game and it comes with these
like little pins i obsessed i need them there's a couple on
ebay there's a couple on ebay and the pins are things like
the sinner sandwich and fk in the coffee and did you hear
that zach stuff like that and i need it i need it i need it
i need it i need it women fear me fish fear me men turn
their eyes away from me as i walk no beast dare make a sound
in my presence i am alone on this barren earth
Wow, did you see that guy?
I have to get it.
I will be getting one.
I need one.
I just want the pins so bad.
Glad it isn't anything spoilery.
There was one that I did not understand.
But I couldn't tell if it was like the dev or not.
Give Minky a fish, she'll be happy for a day.
Give Minky a fish and rod, she'll be happy for the rest of
her afterlife.
So...
True.
I think this is the longest we've heard.
Life is beautiful.
This is the longest!
Do you have a PO box to send pins?
I do.
There's the Densetsu PO box.
That's my Oshi super passionate soulmate.
It's- I just am a collector of things that I love and I love
this game.
I think so.
The kazoo gets me every time.
We don't usually reach this part.
Yeah!
Alright, here we go.
That was the perfect ending.
Why is he like mind controlling the...
Look at the rod.
He's using the force on the fish.
What is happening?
Fish!
Oh my god.
Emily!
What happens if I get Emily?
Wait, what is this?
Was this how you fished in this game?
Fishing, Zach.
We've caught something to brag about now.
First try?
For all the history of the FBI, I'm probably the only one
who fished out documents thrown into a waterfall.
Don't you think so, Zach?
I got the papers.
First try?
I just don't believe it.
from a water bottle.
That's what you don't believe.
I don't believe that this entire thing happened.
Weird looking fish.
What if it has documents and fish?
For eternal life and eternal power, make four human
sacrifices on rainy nights, each after eating the seeds.
Two, make sure that the sacrifice eat the seeds too before
they die.
Three, the sacrifice must also not speak they are being
killed what does that all mean it's called the legend of the
new raincoat killer no George have you ever seen this
handwriting yes it's Thomas's sure George I need to take
these documents something fishy about these documents he
said he'd tell me everything once I take the docks to him
Those are classified.
I can't allow a civilian to view them.
Especially that deranged old goat who owns most of the town.
I agree with George.
Harry is...
How can I put it?
He might be dangerous.
Mr. Stewart, dangerous?
You don't need to worry.
You said it yourselves, didn't you?
Should we shave?
There has never been a mass murder case in this town.
That means these documents pertain to a case that never
actually happened.
Just look at it as though they never actually existed either
Ridiculous York, I'm sure you've got a plan or something in
mind No Okay, you have my approval George George loves us I
think George loves us We need to continue looking for Thomas
At this point, yeah Our search May just become a hunt Life
is beautiful with that Minto deadly primitive audition
stream I'll go see Harry alone the dogs from the dogs go
jumbo does it again do we have a plan I think Zack has a
plan he's gonna he's gonna be like Zack what's the plan if I
hadn't seen it for myself but Thomas there's got to be a
rational explanation for this I don't think it's Thomas
women won me women one fish, me fear me.
Zach, George has started to change.
Yes.
I think the deaths of Becky and Diane had a deep effect on
him.
I guess this town truly is without a king now.
So we're just one death away now for the four deaths.
If the last one counted.
Oh, that was fast.
New Raincoat killer.
I didn't even, I guess I finished.
Wait, I don't get to continue fishing?
I like him that in this he's cleanly shaven I want to do
more fishing I want to fish oh boy I can't hear you let's
pay Harry and have a busy and get to the bottom of all this
fit games I do like spending a bit of time investigating Oh,
I also enjoy being able to hear the game.
I don't know what you're saying.
What was that, Zach?
Where are we?
I guess this is the waterfall-ish area?
What's it say?
End of the tunnel.
Light at the end of the tunnel.
Okay.
Can I take this car?
Whose car is this?
Oh, whoops.
Nothing out of place here.
This is what?
What's going on here?
Wait.
Oh, oh, yes, Kisa!
Oh, you guys are here!
Hello!
You?
I don't want these kids to be put in any more danger.
Hi!
We saw someone.
did Isaac Isaiah what exactly did you see someone in the
forest standing under Anna's tree not a goddess a little
different a ghost yeah maybe it was a ghost ghost what makes
you think that we found this on the ground there when a
ghost dropped this me under Anna's tree out of focus photo
let me see it's blurry and out of focus I can make out two
people but not their faces so that's why they think it was a
ghost but then who was under Anna's tree
all right we got a new quest I guess view list someone in
the forest someone is walking in Anna's forest in the early
afternoon when the weather is clear give this person the out
of focus picture know once you have found out who the ghost
is.
Oh, our beard disappeared for a second.
Did you guys see that?
Can I pet the dog?
Oh, dang, no.
Where did the goddess go?
Closed.
What time is it anyway?
6.
6 p.m.
Ghost beard.
Schrödinger's beard.
Let's look inside.
Let's just take a little peek.
My Shindee, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you, thank you.
I looked away for one second.
It's okay, the VOD exists.
Just don't forget, it's very important.
Whose house is this?
I'm just looking through somebody's home.
Yeah, hello VOD.
Watchers.
Hello, hello.
Potato.
I could go for a potato right now.
Who is that?
What is this?
Why is there a door here?
It works.
There's a double door here.
Alright, let's go back to Mr. Stuart.
To Harry.
Harry Stuart.
Wait, where is Anna's forest even?
I don't even remember.
When the gate is closed, I guess.
Oh, here's our car.
Vidgames.
If I go this way...
We are getting closer.
Fishing?
I have to go find a fishing point.
Oh my god.
I'm not even on the gas you guys.
Wait, I'm gonna floor it.
Ah!
Just my imagination.
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay?
Are you guys all right?
I think we're fine.
I think we're okay.
Four is looking good.
Alright, watch.
It's a straight shot.
Shoot.
We're fine.
Is there any more money over here?
No.
How am I supposed...
Wait, what the hell was it?
Did you guys see that?
What was that?
There was like a goat or something up here.
Did you guys see that?
Can I get out of the car?
There was a goat?
Or...
There was an animal.
Zach, did you want to go somewhere before we visit Harry?
Yes.
That's fine by me.
I need to see it with my own two eyes.
Can I even get up there?
Please!
Must have been my imagination.
It's really nice here.
Oh, a loss of money too.
Holy money!
Look at all the money!
Don't forget she's the best driver in Dead City.
Oh, there's a dog here!
Hello.
Because there's a bone here.
In the tree.
There's a bone in the tree.
Yes.
I got a hip bone.
Sexy.
A human bone?
This doesn't look related to the case, but shouldn't I let
someone know?
I killed them birds.
That bone kills your frame rate.
bottom right, kind of wispy to see though.
You guys, did anybody else see the goat?
Did anyone else see the goat?
Am I crazy?
You did, yes?
You missed it?
That's okay.
What's wrong with, what, what, what, what the dog doing?
Oh, wait!
It's there!
There was one, there was one!
It was up there!
Yeah, the deer, the deer!
The dog is upset that we took the bone.
It's lost its purpose.
You saw something.
Yeah, we saw it.
We saw it.
Blah, blah, ritual, I beg you.
I see the goat bottom right of screen.
Yeah, that's my goat.
That's my goat.
Okay, I'm going to drive really carefully now.
There it was again!
It was there, it was there.
Look how carefully I'm driving.
I've taken no damage.
Don't listen to that.
I need to go this way.
I think.
Seth, you can take a rest if you're tired.
Yeah?
You let me?
Oh!
Who did that?
Who put the rocks in the road?
This is a road, right?
I feel like I've been here.
And this is not the way that...
Oh my gosh.
No!
I've been here already!
I got baited!
There's a road like around here.
The deer.
Where are all these deer coming from all of a sudden?
There's a railroad.
And then there's a road road right here.
Gotta do a bit of a wide turn.
All right.
We can make it before our car breaks, probably.
Is that 64, 63%?
62, 61, 60, 59?
58 57 56 55 it's fine hmm nothing we're fine just my
imagination yeah everything's fine guys we'll make it before
it breaks down we'll make it we'll make it oh sorry 54 that
wasn't on purpose it might have looked like it it might have
looked like i was heading straight for the rocks and that i
turned into them to also head straight for the rocks but it
was it was it wasn't so intentional as it may have seemed
any deer around here
i bet we can get there above um above 30 percent we're at 45
43 sorry um 42.
Oh, shoot.
40.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, hold on.
We'll get there above 30, though, for sure.
Are you sure?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, I just said so.
I just said I'm sure.
Why?
What's wrong with my car?
I need a second.
I'm not even hitting anything.
Okay, we got to 29%.
But that's not my fault.
I think there's something stuck to my car.
or is broken
no way okay see oh no way we I get it to 29% we were so
close to 30% dang it we were so close we were so close Mr.
Francis York Morgan, finally you have arrived.
You are welcome to come inside.
So says.
Me.
All right, we're back in this hellscape, let's go.
Oh, it's dark.
Why is it so...
Hello?
No.
Looks like the next game is hide and seek.
Huh?
Yeah, we didn't even get greeted this time.
Uh-oh.
No, dungeon two?
We didn't get greeted.
No!
Not in this place!
I mean, I knew it was gonna happen.
Oh, geez.
Robbing me.
The place still looks nice, though.
Besides the veins on the vines and stuff the statues but oh
what's this wow wait a second Zach do you see the
resemblance all right indeed I do Becky she looks like Diane
and Carol Zach look oh that scared me Emily Emily
Oh no!
These styrofoam statues collapsed!
Whatever shall we do?
Oh my...
Oh, there's a bunch of stuff on the ground here.
Be careful.
Let's run it down some.
My goodness.
Shotgun shells?
High quality beef!
Yeah!
Living in luxury here.
Okay.
So far, we have two doors there, and one big door down here.
Boss rush?
Aw.
Come here.
I'll shoot you.
Oh, oh, I did get two of them.
Nice.
We did it.
We solved the puzzle.
I'm just gonna reload real quick.
Hey, man.
Thanks for everything you do for us.
Oh, thank you, Firelander.
Thank you so much for 27 whole months.
Really, really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Oh, we can't go into these.
Okay.
They're too hairy.
Harry Stewart.
All right, that was easy.
Nice shot, boys.
Thank you very much.
Oh, there's money down there and person down here.
Don't want to die.
Shotgun is so awesome.
Shotgun is great, great, great.
Let's go down here first.
I might get ambushed.
But money.
Which I totally need.
Oh.
That guy scared me.
That guy spooked me.
Hello?
Can I get around you?
Oh, I can.
That's easy.
The turkey sandwich!
never get over that color of the sandwich.
Can we go in here?
Observe.
Don't like the look of this.
There's no way to open this one.
Okay.
What do you mean?
There's no way.
Why is it black?
No, I think why is it purple?
That's kind of the question I have for it.
We're taking it easy.
Wait, it's like a super winding.
It's like mega windy.
Don't come out.
Alright, let's go to the door that we need to go to.
The one that was red.
Before we do all this nonsense.
Because it could be.
I mean, we'll have to come here eventually.
But we should know what we're doing first.
Yeah, it was a little blue.
No.
Cabages can be purple.
I guess that's true.
blueberry sauce maybe
okay oh
oh I hear somebody breathing hello hello there's something
in the middle that we need I'm just gonna get my shotgun
ready yeah who's
He's flushing the toilet now!
Oh, nah.
That guy has an arm in his head.
Some of them aren't even facing me.
Oh my god, I'm stuck on your body.
Nice!
I had a feeling the barrels were like that.
Very beautiful.
Just stand in there, okay.
Ouch!
Oh, whoops, wait.
Oh, it's not.
Oh, lady.
I missed you.
Oh, great.
That was a pretty funny animation.
I'm glad we got to see that.
Is that it?
Very nice.
you know what i'll take it i got a golf club
she was walking backwards because she's just too stunned
she's like you're too handsome i can't look at you ever feel
that way about somebody ah oh really
at someone and you're just like you're too you're too
attractive I can't look at you
oh an illusion of the window breaking
go in the chat says me let's stop you guys are being silly
you guys are being silly right now we could shape who's in A
knife worm.
No, no, no.
Is there somebody in here?
In the save room?
No?
Why do I hear groan and moan?
When starting a rush, when I was working retail, a woman
came up to me to ask a question.
She was so beautiful, I almost tripped.
That sounds like an anime moment.
right there wait let's um let's check our sanity and stuff
our food is actually quite good we've been grabbing turkey
sandwiches and stuff we could take a nap let's sleep for
like an hour A light sleep.
Z, Z, Z.
And then we'll eat.
We'll have...
Oh, we'll have...
Some crackers.
You stuffed your face.
I'm stuffing my face with crackers.
we could have the purple turkey not yet not yet not yet
do i have anything do i have anything like a katana in my
inventory okay put away uh put away Oh, we have these things
just with us.
Oh, a flare?
For what?
I have a hot dog with me.
Let's go.
Okay, we can still get other things.
You can get one.
Yeah, I have to buy it.
Okay.
I won't shave yet.
That's a weird painting.
Okay.
All right.
Hot dog, it checks out.
I don't know where I was hearing all this huffing and
puffing from.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
It's like they're right here.
Where?
Oh, you.
We're outside now?
That's kind of cool.
Oh, whoops.
I'm so bad at aiming sometimes.
Don't want to die!
Ro!
Thanks for the hot dog.
Thank you guys for all the hot dogs.
Hot dogs.
I probably...
I'll use a small...
I'll use a small.
Um...
First aid kit, why not?
There we go.
Now if we grab another one, we'll actually keep it.
We'll pick it up.
This is neat.
We're outside.
This is where we were talking to him before.
Are those a bunch of...
No, those are statues in there, right?
My man's taking a nap.
Thank you.
Oh.
Dang it.
Of course.
Stop.
I hate when they come at me!
Stop it.
I'm trying, I'm trying to kill you.
There will be nobody left in this town once I'm through.
Nice shot.
Thank you very much.
Or maybe this...
Maybe that's where we were talking to him.
Yeah.
This is so good-ness.
Can you imagine, like, that's your view?
Sharpshooter, me too.
Ah!
Amazing.
She got the club.
She whacked me over the head.
That was actually a pretty solid one.
Whack!
We were full health just then.
Is this where we need to go?
Oh, we cannot go.
That's fine.
Long, ominous hallway.
That was good.
That was good the way he came out like that.
That was quite spooky, actually.
That was pretty spooky.
Yeah, that was cinematic.
I like that.
I'm gonna just get this ready, though, just in case.
Clearly, it's Zach telling York he's amazing, or the
opposite.
No.
He's...
I mean...
He's telling...
Oh, hello.
He's telling Zach amazing.
But who else could Zach be?
Except me being awesome.
Oh.
Dang!
Okay, buddy.
Yippee!
So true.
Great bullseye.
Great.
Amazing.
Great bullseye.
Is this one we can...
Locked with a padlock.
I should be able to break this if I hit it hard enough.
Our Lord Harry seems intent on playing his little game.
Our Lord Harry!
Oh.
You kill...
More bullets!
Lord Harold!
Okay.
Nice.
Was worth it?
I'm gonna reload.
And we're gonna shoot.
Mr. Harold.
So says Mr. Steele.
stewards.
The statue gets me every time.
So spooky.
What's in here?
Perhaps a save room?
Yes, indeed.
Oh.
Throw away!
It's full of murky water, a sickly blackish red color.
Wait, what is this?
A flare!
You know what I love is that he'll flush the toilet, but he
does not stick his hand in the toilet like every other
disgusting, nasty, uh, protagonist, horror game, survival
horror game protagonist, who's like, I guess my only option
is to stick my hand in this face.
filthy, nasty toilet.
He's just like, I'll flush it.
I'm not afraid.
James?
I wasn't gonna name names.
But can you imagine how James smelled when he met up with
everybody?
I don't wanna, I don't wanna imagine.
Oh, what's going on here?
here.
Wasn't there dirty needles in that too?
I actually don't know.
I don't remember.
Let's see.
There was also this way.
Aha!
Let's...
Let's just go this way.
Hypothetically speaking, if you yourself, Minto, were in
Silent Hill, and the key you need to survive is in a toilet,
and there's simply no other way to get it out, what would
you do?
Simply die with your dignity intact?
I mean, the guy doesn't even realize how many people played
Silent Hill.
Everybody saw him do that.
Everybody saw him doing that, and now what if it's, I'm in
the same situation?
Everybody's just gonna watch me and laugh and point at me,
and say, hey, she had to stick her poopy hand.
She got her hand all stinky.
She had to stick her hand in the poopy toilet.
Now she got a poopy hand.
Folks break the toilet bowl so it drains.
Right!
Oh no!
Wait a second.
No, it's all broken.
Just kidding.
Hey, I was about to go through there.
Down, down, down, she's...
Where are you looking at, lady?
I'm over here!
Down.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom.
Oh,
I think I messed up.
That was too soon.
I guess I really don't need to use my shotgun for this,
but...
You know, it's about...
Actually, can I...
Can I do this?
Oh my gosh, please, if I can.
Anybody else?
Oh!
Literally next to me.
How did you miss?
Oh, that's not right.
There we go.
There's two of them.
Three of them.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, let's just take care of this now.
Hmm.
Sounds like she goes shhh.
Oh, oh no, that's awkward.
Oh, thank goodness he's also waiting for me.
Thank you.
How awkward.
Gosh, that was so awkward.
Sorry, man.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh!
Now he won't wait.
Yeah, he's so polite and patient.
He's like, I get it, buddy.
This is a fair fight.
I'll wait for you.
We love...
How many do I get?
Actually, I just realized.
I'm getting shotgun shells.
I'm reading 12.
But it's a 12 gate.
You know what I mean?
Let's see.
I don't want to accidentally run out because I'm being Lucy.
70!
Okay, we're good.
I was like, I'm being so loosey-goosey with them.
But we're totally fine!
Yippee!
Yeah, the game is giving me a ton.
It's so awesome.
Where are we now?
Okay.
What's over here?
Don't shatter.
I'm scared.
I'm sensitive to noise.
Long, long, long hallway.
I bet that door that I had gone through?
Oh no, there's a lock on this one.
Hmm.
Lots of money.
Is there somebody in here?
Whose closet is this?
Oh!
Oh, the cleaning lady!
How does she do that?
Yeah, we can break the lock.
We will.
She came and went to go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah!
That was so awesome.
What did I get?
What is it?
Oh, first aid kit.
Yippee!
Yeah!
It was like the, it was the longest cutscene for her
entrance.
Mr. Harold Stewart.
Are you a fashionista?
Whose clothes are these?
Ooh, la la!
You can actually read ghost subtitles on PS3 version?
Really?
Wait!
Are we close to what they're saying?
The don't want to die?
Well, don't want to die is very obvious, but...
Bro's dripped out.
Um...
I want to see the other way first.
Oh, what the?
Oh.
Where did you come from?
Whoa, where did you both come from?
I'm just going to keep you.
Whoa, there's three of you.
Do-do-do.
Hmm.
I've been right so far.
Nice.
Don't forget to Reload before fights.
I don't, right?
I sometimes forget.
Sometimes I remember.
Sometimes I forget.
Like here.
I remembered.
This is such a...
They're both...
Oh.
I was gonna say they're both such long-haul...
Emily?
Emily!
At times, we must purge things from this world because they
should not exist.
What's happening?
Even if it means losing someone that you love.
Papa?
Huh?
Stop!
Throws an invisible ball.
What is happening?
Zach, did you see that?
I must be getting tired.
We just napped, buddy.
That was a pretty bad hallucination.
I think.
We will go through here.
And then we'll go back to the locked door.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, we're in here.
We'll go back to the locked door.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're going to...
No, we're here.
We're here.
It's fine.
Who cares?
We're here.
It's fine.
Maybe.
Oh, the statue scared me.
There are multiple buttons.
I know I am indecisive.
There's a switch on those statues.
Should we push it?
Would be fine if the mansion transforms into something
unexpected.
I don't know about that.
Um...
There's no indication to which when we press.
I'm tempting.
Beep.
What does that mean?
Do I have to get them both at the same time?
Oh gosh, the timer music is so stressful.
Beep.
It really did transform into something unexpected.
Do we go back to that other door?
I know these puzzles are making my brain go wackadoo.
How was I supposed to figure that out?
I'm gonna go check out the other door.
Because I broke the lock on it already.
passage open.
We're okay.
I feel like maybe we should have gotten to the other one
first, but that's fine.
Probably.
We're okay.
York.
York's got good stamina, right, buddy?
You're not gonna get tired on me, right, buddy?
Open sesame.
Oh my gosh.
It was just a loop.
Okay.
But, actually.
Actually, this is fine.
We didn't even try this door before, so I didn't know that
it was going to be locked.
I would have known then.
But we will save because we are about to go into the freaky
basement.
I looped the loop.
Nice.
Yes, the base mint.
The base mint.
All right, we running, we running.
No time to lose.
Don't do the bubble tea, Emo.
You're making me want bubble tea.
No, I want bubble tea.
Is he down here, Mr. Stewart?
in your man cave?
No!
Stop!
Gotta hydrate.
I have water.
I'm being good.
Here we go!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Good thing I saved.
What's the problem?
Now we have an issue?
York?
York, what's wrong?
That does sound like a problem now, does it?
Okay, let's keep going.
What was that?
Oh, was that the sound of the door locking?
It's lacked.
Must have been the win.
Oh, he's turning around.
Wait, that's so cinema.
That's...
So good.
That was awesome.
What's going on here?
Zack.
Looks like we're out of the countryside and back in
civilization.
A computer.
What is that?
Welcome, York.
Hold on, I'm gonna eat some pretzels.
I brought the documents.
I'm a little hungry.
Just what is going on in here?
The news.
I warned you about haste.
Take it slow.
You'll lose sight of what's important if you just rush past
it.
As an agent of the FBI, I'm sure you know.
So many people, they think speed is the key.
That
beat.
They're satisfied with what the speed brings.
The speed runs?
A speedrunner's taking strays right now?
Do you like my awesome evil basement history?
I see everything that they don't.
From here, I see it all.
Then, when the time comes, I make use of what I've seen.
But, in this way, anything at all.
You're certainly talkative today, Harry?
Yeah, certainly it's not a boss fight here.
Tell me everything you know.
Speed is not important.
Timing is what is important.
Timing.
York, you have a natural gift for waiting for the correct
timing.
What happened with the recording?
Just be careful that your haste does not ruin.
York, I know more than you think, but less than what you
hope.
One.
You have Nick in custody.
Two.
Thomas is missing.
Yes.
Three.
Carol has a locket that belongs to the murderer.
Yes.
I also know that this case revolves around the red seeds.
But that's about it.
So you've got an inside line on police information.
That reminds me.
The victims' tongues were cut out, weren't they?
They were.
Jill sandwich?
It does have its own version, I guess.
Okay.
Harry, I'm impressed.
You gather information really well.
You hacked into the FBI network, too.
Amazing.
But I didn't come here to hear this.
My man is going through the Matrix in here.
Let us close the business seminar.
Okay.
It's time for a history lesson instead.
Sure?
Where, how did we get in there?
I don't think we need the...
It was dark, rainy, or foggy night.
The Echo.
My parents normally got along.
My father was blaming my mother on seeing it.
We'd
done that day to celebrate the tower's completion.
See the town from above.
And so I decided to climb the tower.
Uh-huh.
The clock tower mentioned, for real.
Curious, child.
Saw it being constructed day after day.
I'm not sure why, but I was really drawn to the town.
Is that old, Mr. Stoeler?
That's why I know.
From the pit in the field, you're
headed to the center.
I hope you're ready for the real nutty plot.
What?
That's young, Mr. Stewart.
There's little suspenders and all.
Aliens.
Oh, sorry.
What is happening?
There were soldiers there, all wearing gas masks.
Huh?
Soldiers?
Are they using this town as like a...
I saw that they were fiddling with some kind of device.
I got the evil laugh.
Smoke outside.
I'll just say, for the first time,
as fast as I could.
I got outside again.
The purple fog was spreading.
I covered my nose.
You can't run the whole way, man.
I've tried doing that.
I just recounted the number of times the bell rang after the
12th time the bell did.
Okay.
Everything's on fire?
Oh, literally everything.
The people who are attacking each other.
Rapid aging as they would say.
Not
particularly strong.
Oh, wow!
What is going?
What?
An expression I have never seen before.
What is going on?
The following morning, I...
It wasn't raining anymore, and the purple fog was gone.
Why is York looking around like, that guy get in here?
I saw, and what I myself had done.
But even worse things were waiting on me.
anything you accident my mother was dead killed presumably
also by my father the next day the town
backwater was issued talking about the incident was
unappreciated a taboo unappreciated is a way to put it
stopped going outside when it rained country folk are very
patriotic we never tell our children about what happened but
these things find a way out of even the tightest of lips in
parts people only speak of the killer in the red raincoat
which is where the legend of the raincoat killer comes from
you're quite a story father your papa after the incident the
gas seeped into the soil of the town.
Even today when it rains, the mountains will rest.
That's why I never take my mask off when I'm outside.
This town is dirty.
You're...
That's why he has it on.
The killer is someone who is badly affected when it rains.
You need to draw the conclusion.
Is there a connection between the red seeds and the gas
then?
This is just my own presumption.
The seeds and the gas have a similar effect on our nervous
systems.
I believe someone figured that out and decided to use it.
Or it could just be nature's way of getting back at us
humans.
What if they made the gas out of the seed?
Good news!
You hear from George soon.
They have found Thomas.
They found him!
and very important.
Attention, Thomas!
Yeah?
Just as you suspected, everything I have told you is
gibberish.
Of course.
I never hacked into the FBI, sir.
No, I won't tell anybody.
And I certainly know nothing about the Red Seeds.
I shall thank you for listening to an old man, Babylon.
Let me ask you one thing then, Harry.
You're a businessman.
You must be after something in return for giving me this
information.
Hmm.
What business does this guy do, actually?
At times, we must purge things from this world because they
should not exist.
Even if it means losing someone that you love.
Hey.
This dude does not justify murder.
Nevertheless, everything changes in the future.
Ooh, he said the same thing as my dad.
There isn't a single thing that can be done to ensure
The sacks are going crazy right now.
Holy cow.
What the heck?
Sometimes though, foreshadowing.
Sometimes though, I think when we're going into this
nightmare mind palace of ours, I wonder if like maybe like
how did we find you know how how is it that we found mr
stewart down there what if we were really being led by by by
his assistant the entire entire time and we're just like
while like following him and walking around like and he's
just like this this way to the next side yeah we're just
shooting around going crazy like that's how that's how
that's my head cannon that's how i imagine it but wow what
what a lore drop that was what the heck is going on what is
happening this is this is a ridiculousness meanwhile york is
literally nightmare world yeah seriously yeah so the
military is being evil and doing evil laughs as they pump a
scary purple mist into this town using the people like
guinea pigs testing their freaky gas that makes you violent
and upset and walking along being like Lord Lord Lloyd
fighting his inner divas it's true
everybody rioted but no one talks about yeah so many people
died and they're just like yeah maybe we shouldn't bring
that back up maybe we don't tell our kids they made a clock
tower just to be evil on it just to be up there and pump the
gas into the whole town the the fact that it's so potent
this gas is so potent that every time it rains people are
going on rampages wow yeah they're just laughing about it
violent and upset yeah clock tower evil i've never heard of
that ever in my afterlife what did they need the bell to
ring for though yeah the 13 rings right the 13th bell and
the first raincoat killer was his dad well what happened to
his dad then he didn't really say anything he just said that
he knocked him out and now we know nothing hmm his mom was
dead dad gone
We're so, from this one case that we've been here for about
like a week, we've made almost $20,000 in a week.
York is loaded.
That was a really good cutscene.
That whole segment was so good.
That's so awesome.
Oh, when launched, a patrol car will come.
Okay.
Okay, good to know that's how you use the flare.
uh-oh oh it's raining oh i'm feeling i'm getting i'm getting
angry emily york we found thomas ah he's at his house right
how did you know that we didn't check his house
Oh, she wants us to drive!
Let's get a move on.
That's so funny.
Wait.
I don't know where his house is.
Zach, things are finally starting to come together.
All we need now is for Tom.
She didn't check his house?
Okay.
Emily, oh Emily, my lovely little Emily.
Wee-woo, wee-woo, wee-woo.
Let's floor it, baby!
Wait, how do I turn on the windshield wipers?
Wipers on.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Sorry.
Oh!
Wow!
This one is really, really zippy.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Oh,
I was looking at the how to turn the wipers on.
Oh my god.
I can barely turn with it.
This is insane.
Whoa!
Neo Serperis, you caused that.
Hi, Vod.
It's good to hear.
You, I'll catch in Vod.
Just got passed up for promotion, found out about it from
the rest of the apartment, so that's my day.
Hope you and the rest of...
Oh.
No.
No, you didn't cause that.
You didn't cause it.
Oh, Neo Serperis.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry boss no why no I was just kidding I was just
kidding oh I'm sorry George doesn't do anything stupid York
let's go okay I'm really sorry that sucks so much in fact
you had to hear it from everybody else too it's a stinky
roll probably yeah they make you put your hands in toilets
probably yeah you'll get them next time or you'll find
something better that's that's how life tends to be funny
like that you know sometimes really I mean in the moment of
course it's gonna you get you have every right to be upset
have every right to be sad about it but you know there will
be always another opportunity and ultimately something
better will happen and better will come Yeah, blessing in
disguise sometimes.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
That goes for everybody, too.
Is it me or is the car going slower?
Did I break it?
Sure hope not.
Like, it feels easier to control all of a sudden.
I say that, but actually...
The game keeps lagging every time I'm driving recently.
Oh,
tree.
Cars.
Is this a road?
Yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
We're gonna churn here.
Mint sings the sun will come out tomorrow.
I'm Annie.
Minty.
The sun will come out tomorrow.
Bet your bottom dollar.
Slow Turner, oh my gosh.
God, that guy's gonna kill somebody.
That tomorrow There'll be signs.
Just thinking about Tomorrow.
I don't remember the words actually.
Extra for long distance.
Is that what that was?
Come what may.
Tomorrow, tomorrow.
I love you tomorrow.
You're only a day away.
Wait, you think I can go through this?
I learned what I learned.
When you're stuck with a day that's gray and lonely, I just
take on my chin and green and say,
The sun will come out tomorrow.
something about the sun tomorrow.
Oh, Fiona!
Fiona's trying to kill us!
Where the hell did you come from?
Okay, I know a lot of these are probably my fault, but she
literally just ran like the stop sign.
Fiona!
Fiona's like, I'm just trying to get home.
Fiona's like, I got him, I found the killer.
It might be the maniac that's driving through the streets
that guy is horrible we received an anonymous call informing
us that thomas returned home i sent emily to get you right
away no idea who made the call an anonymous caller that's
why i came on ahead to see if the information was correct a
light did come on but only for a second i saw a tall male
silhouette in the window how do you know you know his
silhouette i'm going in there you two wait here Wait, what?
Why?
We'll be ready to burst in at any moment.
Just call out.
Or we all go in together.
Oh man, I'm gonna have to go into the nightmare.
It's the same in the countryside after all.
The climax of an investigation is always inevitable.
Is it?
In the apartment.
The climax.
Tactical pose, York.
So awesome.
Are we...
Why is this so sexy in here?
Hello?
Sexy Thomas!
Is he gonna come out in some lingerie or something?
What's happening?
He got groceries and everything.
I saw a banana.
Not his, luckily.
But...
He's got a nice record player.
Wow!
This song is already finished playing.
It's not even a cutscene.
What was this song?
You are an idiot.
It's this song.
Found out that MC of Esoteric Eb is technically a detective,
so you might not know.
might enjoy that one oh thank you strike thanks for the
super chat too he looks like he's just vibing to the music
isn't this a the song his sister sings that's the one at the
club right or it is his sister that sings is it is the one
at the club though carol yeah yeah yeah one second real
quick you guys can vibe give me like actual one second
my blanket is stuck on my chair there we go all
right let's start profiling!
That was Thomas, no?
That looks like the upside down piece.
Someone's running away?
Carol?
too much noise we're still missing a vital piece of the
puzzle three probably yep there it is
what is it oh Jerry pie that's all you've got in your fridge
oh we didn't see that before that's a little peculiar now
isn't it this is so actually with the song playing and the
creepy music too it's all so creepy.
Uh-huh.
You were mid tomato cut.
Thoroughly polished.
Mary a speck of dust inside.
We love a clean king.
Let's go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Not yet, not yet.
Wait.
Are we?
Where?
Wait, are we in somebody else's house?
What's that?
Thomas's biscuit!
That looks delicious.
Thomas's biscuit looking real good.
A red wig.
This confirms our suspicions, Zach.
This confirms our suspicions.
You got red wig.
Yes, we'll profile, I guess, with the new wig.
Wow.
So that's Thomas.
Is he like getting changed or something?
Oh!
Was he dressed?
Wait.
We took it for ourselves.
Was that...
Was that Thomas?
Was that Thomas getting into a sexy red dress for the
killer?
Why are we in somebody else's house?
his house now observing I'm observing huh this a series of
boot prints culprit must have entered entered this room wet
but but boot boot sorry I can't speak sometimes I think a
Lord loiter has made me anyway i can't speak because of okay
so the killer comes in
i got my cat one of those water fountains from oh so now the
room constantly has a running water sound as a secondary
consequence i've been remembering to drink more water not
from the fountain phil wait cats love those i love watching
my cat go
awesome.
Yay!
I'll drink more water.
Yeah.
Drink more water.
A single coffee.
Oh, oops.
Makes it harder to become sleepy.
Coffee.
It's so cute.
It is.
What was that?
Cigarette.
Heavy.
Oh, these are They're awesome for making the time go.
Whoa!
Hello again, mister.
Thank you so much for the Hakosupa.
I missed the end of Grim Pandango, but congrats on finishing
it.
I was busy during the final, but both Deadly Premonition and
Grim share a lot of DNA.
From clunky controls to being made uncompromisingly by their
directors.
Hope you had a blast with both cult classics.
I am, and I did.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
If there's one thing she takes good care of, it's this
mannequin.
She values her costumes, I figure.
Turn on.
Turn it on.
I love this song, though.
I want it.
I want one of this song, too.
A record player apparently quite old.
It's as if the people in this town live back in the good old
days.
a lollipop why is it why is it so shiny do they make I know
that there are I know that there are vinyl or record players
that can switch like the side of the of the vinyl but do
they like make them still I guess like are they kind of
easily easy to get 5 frame per second lollipop bottle?
Yeah?
Wait, I feel like I did not grab this.
Maybe I did.
It's just the brightest lollipop ever.
They're not very common nowadays, but they do make them.
Expensive, but yes.
I figured it would be pretty expensive, right?
Dang.
Oh, this is where the killer...
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What's in the other door?
Record players are still being made.
Oh, yeah, I have one.
I have one.
I listen to it like almost every day.
Okay, there we go.
That's my curiosity.
Saciated.
Yeah, I listen to mine all the time.
But sometimes it's like, you know, there can only be so many
songs on one song.
of a record so it's like it's like oh if only i could have
one that would automatically flip it to the other side i
would say that i mean there are definitely cheaper vinyl or
record players but i would it's something i wouldn't cheap
out on because they can scratch your vinyl so easily and
then um and then ruin your your your vinyls so unfortunately
it's something you need to like not cheap out on even though
there are some that are that are very cheap so yeah
gotta keep them safe i know because they're like kind of
expensive they're expensive and maybe you've got like one
that's kind of rare or something you know thomas's shoes the
shoes were found in the bathtub they are wet which means the
person didn't have time to take them off
thomas's shoes time to profile put it all together baby
oh yeah
profiling start
Oh.
He's getting dressed.
You know that image though of the raincoat killer?
Kind of doing something for me.
I get it.
Oh!
So there's
more to it.
I have like the bonus footage on a DVD.
I hope it's worth watching.
Don't you agree?
in what was that noise you scared me damn it we need to seal
off all routes out of town no need for that george he's
still here under his bed if he was going to leave town he
would have done so by now that's true which means he's still
got some unfinished business killing emily
What is this?
What is this smirk on his face?
Do you want to shave?
I mean save?
No.
Yanwei, thank you!
Did you know during the Cold War vinyl records couldn't be
brought into the USSR?
Music fans discovered that discarded x-rays could be used to
press their own records.
This is called bone music, and the records look rad as heck.
I bet!
Oh my god, he's running in 10 frames per second.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, oh, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's me on the road.
Wait, hello?
Don't you think they heard what I said?
Aren't you forgetting someone?
We don't have to make a fuss.
Thomas isn't going to leave town.
That gives us plenty of time to find a way to view the bonus
footage.
Bonus footage?
Is it?
Is it what I'm thinking of?
Episode 320, Cruel Devise.
It's all spooky, but...
Oh, look!
Wait!
Oh, some of the places are sealed!
Wait, what the heck?
That's kind of fun.
The uncut version.
We didn't get to see all of it.
Robbing me.
This town is...
This town is bleeding me dry.
Oh, there's a person.
Ah!
Oh my god.
There are people.
Just get in the car.
Get in the car.
Get in the car, York.
Bam bam!
I'm sorry.
Can't hear you.
What?
That was...
Was that a strees sign in the middle?
the road oh oh it's a guy
so where shall we go next
oh oh this is kind of messed up i think
Zombie Minecraft sounds.
Uh...
I hope I'm going the right way.
I mean, it seems like it, but...
Oh!
What's happening?
Uh, it's one of the girls!
I can't remember their names.
There's too many.
What's that?
Anna!
The first one!
Oh.
Honk at her.
No, no, don't get help.
Anna.
Wait, where'd she go?
Anna, baby girl, I lost you.
Come back to me.
There's too many things that are making everything lag.
Oh my god, the music is so loud.
The music that makes you deaf is playing.
This too is cinema, though.
Although,
I lost her.
Not this way, Zach.
I have to keep her in sight.
I can't find her!
Oh, there she is.
What is happening?
This is awesome.
Look at the way she runs.
This is the quietest this music has ever played.
Don't tempt me.
It's honestly...
I love this track.
This is so awesome.
What?
What do you mean?
This is literally the way she went.
This is so awesome.
You don't think this is awesome?
How do you not think this is awesome with the song playing?
Running after a dead lady's ghost?
Being chased by zombies all around?
Mid-chasing women.
This is awesome.
Like, they could have done, like, an action soundtrack,
or...
I mean, we are literally running in circles.
But, they could have done any sort of, like, type of
atmosphere here.
And no.
Like, they...
I don't know.
There's something about it.
I'm loving it.
Where
did the birds come from?
second.
Where did the birds come from?
You work over here!
She's such a tease.
Wait, where did she go?
Wait.
Oh, no.
Ma'am.
Ma'am, you disappeared right here.
Oh, there she is.
Kochi, Kochi!
It's where he can cook.
He just needs money in an editor.
It's true.
What?
Oops, gave her the ick.
That guy is too smelly.
Smells like purple gash.
You can encounter birds and dogs at night in rain.
Oh, it's a dungeon.
Hey!
Time for a little...
A little puff to chill the nerves.
Yeah, me too.
I almost became a goddess of the forest myself.
Although I think the look might suit me.
What do you think, Zack?
Absolutely.
100%.
Okay.
Can we sleep on here?
No, wait.
I don't know about that one, Chief.
I could definitely get some sleep here, Zach.
Wait, sleep here.
Period.
Zach.
Gotta know what Zach is thinking about this guy.
I want to keep playing, so I think we will.
I was wondering if this might be a good place to call it
quits or not, but I want to keep playing, so...
Oh, baby.
Oh.
Where?
What are you gonna do?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Bozo.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow, that one scared me.
They did this on purpose, though.
And we couldn't get ambushed on the sides.
That was kind of cool.
Oh.
No, my song!
What?
Hello?
Sure?
What's happening here?
Okay.
somebody running don't know what that is it's also fast okay
no clue too much noise yeah you're still missing a vital
piece of the puzzle no kidding I love He says that every
time.
That way?
Yes, sir.
Only two pieces this time.
How interesting.
Country ham.
Got a whole thing of ham.
Let's go.
Oh, it's behind here.
Root beer.
Huge.
The whole hand.
It's my bar now.
This is such a vibe.
Love the thumbnail.
Switching to the shoddy.
These... Okay guys.
idea next from Minto with love?
What do you think?
Yes, please.
Boy!
What's going on?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm not ready.
Oh geez, okay.
Oh frick, it's this again.
Okay, we got this.
I'm running, I'm running.
Wait, wait, I wish I could pause so you guys could see.
Hold on.
Oh, push.
Push.
Oh my god, push.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, that was bad.
Ah, he saves me!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running.
Push.
Ah, he's right behind me!
Oh shoot.
Yes!
Go, go, go, push, push, push!
Okay, he's just standing there.
I'm not quite sure why.
He's just standing there.
Okay.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Hey, open!
No rush, no rush.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
We're keep going.
We're going to go.
I don't know what that guy's doing.
Where did he come from?
Wait, what's happening to my jacket?
Where are you hiding?
What's happening?
What happened to my jacket?
Did you guys see that?
My head was blocking a little bit, but...
Oh,
what's happening to my jacket?
What was that?
Or what button while you had to press to hold our breath?
Oh, shoot.
No!
We'll have to do all this over again.
Oh wait, I'm sorry, I'm blocking his view again.
What is it?
R2, I think?
I guess ZR on the...
Or no.
Oh, it was ZR.
Yes, I knew it.
That was close.
That was so close.
That was so close I almost did.
shotgun on him right now.
Probably.
Is that it?
Oh, nope.
The song.
Where are you hiding?
No, I am.
You'll never find me because you don't open the drawers.
You can't smell my breath.
It's minty fresh.
You'll never find me.
I'm not there.
I'm over here.
But I won't tell you that.
deep breath.
You won't smell it, yeah?
I brush my teeth.
Oh, oh, oh.
Brush your teeth.
Brush them, brush them, brush them.
Yeah, you gotta brush your teeth.
Okay, calm down, not Thomas.
He kicked down the door.
I'll need to shut it again.
Oh, go out before we die.
We suffocate in here.
Oh my gosh, so freaking funny.
Zach, this is a waste of time.
Let's go.
Oh, was it a waste of time?
Wow, killer left a whole bunch of cash in here.
Let's go.
My honor is going up through the roof.
I'm due for a promotion, baby.
Zach, this is a waste of time.
These places become ginormous.
Are they going to get us with like a mannequin spook?
What was that?
Is that him?
That has to be.
him dragging his axe
or he was okay just making sure I didn't miss a door
I don't hear it anymore though
the dramatic hallway we haven't found a single clue we suck
at our job maybe we won't get the promotion after all look
at all these dresses.
Ah!
That was so close!
Wait, did I even make it?
No, I didn't.
That's so lame.
Wait!
Wait a second.
We know somebody else that just did that.
second the assistant so says mr.
Stewart mr.
man that says so says man he did that to us too why
are we in the largest bathroom ever oh you got this my man's
fighting for their life in there
The blood stains on the floor lead into this door, but the
door itself is locked.
Oh yeah, there are blood stains, huh?
Very tiny ones.
He's gonna bust down once we walk by.
Wait, whoa, look at that!
That's kinda cool.
I don't wanna peek!
We could peek through if we want.
Okay.
Stick my whole face in there!
there.
Oh, he's up.
Oh, what is that?
Thomas.
Wait, that's Thomas's police bed.
I know how to use the door now.
That zoom in was great.
Okay, lady, we get it.
Oh, that spooked me.
It was so loud.
It got me.
Wait a second.
Kill!
Oh, you're already dead.
I thought you were...
Whatever.
How did that...
I don't know how that got the second person.
That's crazy.
That's crazy work.
Thomas's sheriff badge I'm not gonna profile because there's
only two that we need
What is this music?
What was that?
Put the extra money I think we don't need it I think we're
okay There's only one more that we need Then we'll get the
full picture Okay That excites me more.
No.
Wait, no, no.
What the?
What is going on over there?
Is it the thing that is so annoying?
Yeah, this thing's so annoying.
Yeah.
This thing's so stinking annoying.
Oh.
That's right.
We evade.
There you are.
Yay.
Why?
Oh.
Wait, am I at?
No, there's no way.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Is it gonna come out through here?
Someone is, I imagine.
Where the heck are we?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, you're very annoying.
Yeah, yeah, you're so annoying.
It does bleed purple!
Oh.
Crush?
I don't have any on me?
Yeah, it bleeds purple, just like the purple mist.
Oh, there's a second one.
Awesome.
We love to see it.
Of course.
Who would have?
Who would have thought?
Oh.
I'll
kill you.
Ah, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait.
I pressed B and didn't work.
I guess I could have just walked away from it really
casually.
Oh, okay.
I hate the areas like this, though.
They're not very fun.
Someone's flushing the toilet again.
Okay.
I have cooties now.
I'm now, only now, like, paying attention to the purple.
Hey!
My goodness gracious.
Now I'm seeing the purple smoke everywhere, you know?
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Catch?
like i guess it just didn't register with it yeah now it's
got context yeah exactly that's so fun i hope i don't have
to run through this again like that last dungeon or not the
last one but like there was one that was just like this
before where we kept having to run through and it was real
annoying.
Or rather, we had to run back and we fought the things on
the walls before, too, and take a root beer.
Pretty sure it was the museum, yeah.
No.
Oh, was it like the other thing where I have to run?
Oh.
Huh.
that did it the very first playthrough i saw ended here guy
got so drunk but hurt at running out of ammo at the crawling
and restart his game three years later you've been kicking
butt speeding through the game it could also be maybe he
played the original wait uh don't save yet because i want to
i want to heal real quick it could be that he was playing
the original i heard it was much more annoying than this one
it
was the og yeah yeah it was So, I don't blame him so much,
but let's, uh, let's eat a lollipop.
Actually, I'm quite hungry.
We're gonna have our hot dog!
Ah, yeah!
And we'll, we'll take a nap, too.
Maybe I should have slept first, but actually, we're fine.
We don't need to sleep.
Okay.
Now we save.
Nice.
Wow, it didn't charge me.
No, I wish we could play the record.
I was hoping.
All right, here we go.
Oh.
Awkward.
Just kidding.
What?
What was that?
Turn it on?
Why did you...
What?
Why are you doing that?
There.
There we go.
It was like, you're gonna not solve the puzzle that way,
stupid.
Yeah, save the game this time.
Before we go in there, though, real quick, I'm gonna go grab
some water.
I'm gonna go grab some water so I'll be right back.
Oh, wait a moment.
I stood up.
I have to go to the ghosty's room.
I have to pee.
Okay, I'll be right back again.
I'll be fast.
Come back.
Thanks for the blues.
Thank you for all the blues over time.
Thank you.
Someone.
Curse of Kuhar!
Thank you so much for that.
Hey, gifted.
Thank you.
Tataima!
Tataima, Tataima.
That was such a good face?
You have the silliest AKFK faces?
Do I?
Are you just saying my face is goofy?
Shooty, love you!
Thank you for two years!
Thank you!
Wait, your profile picture is so cute.
What the heck?
Oh
my god, my water's too hot.
I dropped my inhaler.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
I forgot that that's a thing.
I forgot.
I've just been blasting through everything.
I forgot you could actually, like, hold your breath behind
them and they don't see you, allegedly.
We're walking.
We're power walking.
Is the...
Is the raincoat killer gonna be right there?
There's some money.
Dramatic door for what?
Strutting down the catwalk.
Yes.
All right.
Huh.
Is this a maze?
This looks like something I'm gonna have to run around later
on.
Climbing and hooting and hollering all over these things,
you know?
Shotgun, baby.
Holy!
Oh!
They get up on me!
It's so fast!
They're up on me so quickly.
Where's another one?
Oh, there he is.
What's here?
Versailles kit.
I'll take it.
Yeah, you had a golf club, too.
Okay.
All right.
Was it that door over there or something down here?
Don't put your gun away.
What's this?
A sa-a-a-saber?
Wait, what?
I want that!
I need my toolbox right now!
Saber of fate, stay night fame?
You say fate go.
I say fate stay night.
We are two different people.
We are of two different eras.
Hello?
Check this out.
You want to watch?
Well, do you?
Do you want?
Do you?
I got room.
I guess I could push these, huh?
I think it might be better to eventually...
You don't see me?
Wait, come back!
Come back!
Oh, shoot.
Wait, okay.
I thought I was gonna be...
Here she comes, here she comes.
How's your shotgun ammo?
Haven't seen a drop in quite a few.
Me neither.
I was...
Oh, a can of pickles.
I was just thinking that.
I was like, hmm.
I guess we could check.
Oh, oh.
Uh, no.
Oh, here, no.
38.
But my shotgun.
My shotgun.
Does he know?
Yeah, I'll try to one-shot some of these guys more, but
sometimes they're so beefy.
I probably don't need to be using my shotgun here anyway.
I should probably save it, huh?
Missa made him into phantom.
There are quite a lot of enemies to shoot.
Also, you are quite cute.
So says.
Mr. Stewart.
So says Mr. The guy that's our killer, probably.
If I think so, I think so.
So says the guy that I think is murdering the town.
He's all quiet until...
Does that lady have a...
A flamethrower?
Not a flamethrower.
But, like, but, you know what I mean.
What is it?
He had, like, a torch or something?
I need that.
lady.
Give me what you got.
Yes.
Ah!
Oh my god!
That was the scariest thing that has happened this entire
game.
That has been the scariest thing this entire game so far.
Oh, geez.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, there's nothing over here.
Okay, good to know.
Oh, come on.
She went so freaky style!
I didn't like it.
Wait, did she drop it?
I guess not.
It's first aid kit.
Aw, man.
Wait, what is this?
More bullets!
Hello?
Oh.
That was so scary.
All right, all right.
Oh, nice and red in here.
You know what red means?
Red means scary things will happen.
It's like particularly red.
Oh, gosh.
Hey.
Hi.
Oh, no, wait.
Oh, wait.
I did I did be I wasn't I saw evade and I didn't see what
the thing was continue continue okay there we go
okay this is where we start so we just gotta run through
here and then he kicks down that door right there he's
smiling up until that part is so funny See you.
Can you hear my...
me like doing this?
Yeah!
Sick moves, York.
The POV is so crazy.
Everything is on fire.
Push.
Oh, shoot.
push.
Oh, you don't need to push that.
You could have run around that very easily, man.
Nope.
Oh, push.
Okay, we gotta push it some more.
For some reason.
Okay, now we can go.
I don't know where Mr. Stewart, so it says Mr. Stewart is.
I don't even know that guy's name.
I don't know him.
I can't reach out at all because I'm so focused.
Oh, now he's running at me, okay?
It took a sweet, sweet time before knowing that I was
pushing that.
Yeah, it's getting really tired!
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh.
Is he gonna come?
Will you have to hide again?
Oh.
Nope.
We're fine.
Oh.
Is someone gonna get caught I'm fine.
Oh!
What just happened to me?
Whoa!
Wait, what just happened?
Wait.
There's purple... purple smoke there.
What just happened?
That was weird.
Ah, we'll use our hand.
Ah!
Gosh!
Hold on.
I'm gonna heal my Well, no, I'm okay for now.
I think they're getting, they're catching on fire.
But they're also getting me.
Can I climb over anything?
Wait a second.
I don't think my booty can get through here.
Uh.
Where am I supposed to go here?
Yeah, booty too thick.
Um...
Hmm.
I don't think I can smash these ones, no?
They're like part of the environment?
Or... Oh, can I smash these?
Oh!
Oh, I didn't realize that I could.
That's so funny.
Oh gosh, she scared me.
The fire does not kill them fast enough.
Oh, wait, that's not what I meant.
It was just...
Yes, Agent.
Yes.
Killier.
You're dead.
Yeah, you're dead.
Killier.
That was cheap, wasn't it?
I agree.
Okay.
Climb up.
Climb down.
Uh, I think we take certain things in video games.
Whoa!
Way for, they, like, oh my gosh, they go crazy mode.
We take things in video games way too, like, for granted.
You know what I mean?
Like, just being able to climb up and down boxes easily.
I don't like when they do that.
It spooks me.
Oh, we're in this area.
Look at that.
Oh.
What was that?
Big scary sound?
No scary source?
Being able to actually traverse and heard of...
Hello, Gamito.
Hello!
Welcome in.
What an ice pick.
Hmm?
Is that what happened to Thomas?
This isn't how they taught me to use ice picks?
No sirree!
Oh yeah, I'm in the middle, sorry.
Sorry, I got stuck there because I was thinking of, or I
was, I was doing the POV running thing.
So you can see the killer POV.
Okay, time to profile!
Okay.
What?
Oh, that's how you get into the room.
Secret antler room.
Ooh!
Huh?
Oh, geez.
This place is bleeding me dry.
How am I ever gonna...
Oh.
Oh, again.
Alright.
Alright, buddy.
Yeah.
I'm ready for you.
Oh, jeez.
I'm not ready for you.
I'm not ready for you!
Try to move out of the way.
There we go.
We're in the way.
no rush we're in no rush don't even worry about it oh that's
it oh my gosh all of that for what I guess the I guess the
the rain stopped so
you need the ice pick and you stab it in the head.
That's so gruesome.
That's one bizarre setup.
Whoever made this must be crazy.
Agreed.
Aggressive.
It is pretty gnarly.
Oh.
Oh, is there anything?
Oh, it's green now.
I guess not.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, I thought that was a circle of blood.
It's just a rug.
And we go.
If York says they're crazy, they are actually nuts.
This is for real.
The sexy BTS room.
BTS.
It's the sexy room that we've been seeing.
Zach, okay, so it's not bonus footage.
It's still part of the main feature.
Perpetrator is exactly who I thought it was.
First things first.
We'd better let poor Nick go.
This is Carol.
Are you guys sick of this song yet?
I'm actually not.
I can't understand her at all though
What does that mean?
Do you want to be your sister?
Thomas?
Give us a show!
Yeah, baby!
Knock us out and then give us a dance show.
Like, Thomas is like...
York's suit is glitching out.
No, it's just a really strong breeze in here.
Oh.
I wasn't feeling the wig anymore.
Thomas is really affected by the mist, huh?
Did we clear that?
I don't know.
They should have...
George and Emily should have listened to me.
All they had to do was follow me.
I would have...
All they had to do was follow a ghost lady through the town.
Something, I've never seen Twin Peaks.
I really want to.
I've never seen it, but something about that felt extremely
Twin Peaks.
When we were running through the town like that.
Following a ghost lady.
I already follow a ghost lady.
She'll lead you to the bar.
And then you have to go into my nightmare dungeon.
I have so many questions.
Thank you.
Welcome to the club.
Welcome to the question club.
Oh yeah, Zach Ville!
Previously during the investigation.
Okay then, Zach.
Let's pay Harry another visit and get to the bottom of all
this.
And that one?
And that one too.
All red seeds.
Welcome.
You've been to Killings 50 years ago.
There's something about it that you won't find written in
those files.
The people were attacking and killing each other, rampaging
as though insane.
Quite a story.
York!
I told you!
That's nothing more than local folklore.
What does that all mean?
It's called The Legend of the New Rainbow Killer.
York!
We found Thomas.
Zack.
Okay.
So it's not bonus footage.
It's still part of the main feature.
The perpetrator is exactly who I thought it was.
If you watch people's movements on the map carefully, you
can see Thomas and others sometimes being at the restaurant,
but nowhere to be found.
Holy loud.
Come on, boy, or it'll be too late.
Oh, these little stepies.
I was about to stop, but we'll stop when it's a better time
to.
Wait, that's actually so awesome.
That you can see them there, but they're not at the
restaurant.
That's crazy!
Big!
You should join the...
You should submit to Guinness Book of World Records.
Dad, your stride is...
Dad?
Dad!
Come on, boy, or it'll be too late.
Call me York!
That's what everyone calls me!
How to run!
This is how you teach your boy to learn how to run.
Just like how you throw a kid into a pool, they'll learn how
to swim.
Run away from your child to learn how to run.
Come on, boy.
I didn't know we were playing God of War.
Dad?
Come on, boy.
Or it'll be too late.
I'm trying.
No, we gotta run.
Luckily, we don't have stamina here.
I'm just a kid.
I'm always running around.
I got no stamina because I don't need stamina.
I have kid.
Oh, wait, dad?
Wait, I've got kid energy.
Wait, dad?
Dad, for real?
You're not gonna jump scare me, you know what I mean?
Dad?
Come on, boy, or it'll be too late.
Dad, where are you for real?
I saw something shining in the distance.
This part is so long.
the birds are awfully chirpy for this place my dad did that
i almost drowned got traumatized and still don't know how to
swim brian zander morgan are dead dad dad come on boy or
it'll be too late dad why do you have trading card of your
yourself?
Dad?
Dad, can I sell you on eBay?
How much will it go for, Dad?
Do you know the market rate for your car, Dad?
This is the reverse heavy rate.
Dad!
Daddy!
No, don't Don't cry, little York.
He's got such daddy issues.
It's crazy.
Or Emily?
Are you okay?
I told you he saw her as his mom.
I told you.
I
don't think we've gotten this version of the song.
And there's a dog here, too.
Oh.
We finally can pet the dog.
Thank goodness.
Ooh, don't open your mouth.
We're just getting all in there.
Hi, quality beef.
Freud, is that you?
Oh, we're in this area again.
No, the girls are all gossiping about me and laughing about
me!
No!
Oh, or maybe about him.
You are waiting here for someone, aren't you?
The person you will be here soon.
This part still is so... What the heck?
What?
I love our mind palace.
It's just so strange.
We come toward the climax.
said I was soon faded to meet him guys honest question so I
do care for Emily what about you we should take this
opportunity and talk about this a bit um how much longer do
I have at the game because it feels like it's almost over
but I also can't tell oh if I hadn't seen your come into the
bar well you wouldn't have found this place would you now
how about that I guess I've always been lucky when luck was
anybody that's why i've been able to stay in business too
although we have one last stream or a few hours okay then
we'll do another stream he's got a great nose clever too
he'd be a great businessman if he wanted to be i owed you
guys one anyway and i owed your big the horse i want to help
you guys out is there anything i can do oh they found the
room the offer but this is a police matter you can leave
everything to us from here oh well okay George look you're
not at the end but close all good these cigarettes they're
the same brand that York smokes he's definitely been here
yeah because I'm smart and you're stupid are closed last
night This town will be deserted if this keeps up.
What do you think is really happening here in Greenvale?
Emily, let's focus on looking for York.
I just hope there are more leads than a cigarette butt
around here.
Wait, that'd be awesome if we're not York anymore.
For a bit.
This is such a long cutscene, but...
We're in the final act.
I might say it two to three hours.
Hey, Willie, of course.
Thanks, Miss Doove!
You can track his scent, can't you boy?
What do you think, officers?
Let him help you out, why don't you?
Oh, he'd make a fine police dog.
Oh, sorry.
I told you we don't need...
Sounds good, Kaysen.
We need all the help we can get.
Come on, George.
Let's let them help us.
But they are civilians.
Do you have a better plan?
Oh my goodness.
As we speak, your...
Don't yell at me, Emily.
Oh, no.
She loves us.
She's in rubble.
Oh, all right.
Let's have them help.
Thank you, George.
But one thing, with York missing in action, I'm back in
charge.
New York would give me hell if something bad happened to you
guys.
So promise me you'll call for backup at the first sign of
danger.
Yeah!
Yes, of course.
I think we're missing something.
Not even with the angelic version of this song.
You go with Kaysen and follow York's trail.
It's a little bit easier to hear.
Thank you, George.
I like this version.
It's so cute.
We're counting on you, boy.
Welcome to the forest, Deputy Willy.
The version is so good!
Look at that catfish.
Wow.
The whiskers on that, lad.
Oh
Hot dog Oh my gosh, when do we when does it end though?
Let's get rolling then.
Do we now play as Emily?
I'm counting on you willie.
Where are we willie?
Are we willie?
Oh, he barks with his tongue out.
Not counting on me though, are you?
Are you a dog casein?
What is happening?
Where?
Where are you going?
Deputy Willie's over here.
Come on, hurry.
I need a save point.
Oh, yeah, Jet Set Radio finally.
This dog running is...
The animation is wackadoo.
Oh, I guess I'm still playing.
Oh, the game won't let me quit.
Oh, I'm stuck in inside the game.
Oh, someone help me out.
Oh, I need to quit.
Oh, I need to quit the game.
Oh, I'm hungry for dinner.
Oh, I don't know what to quit.
Oh, the game won't let me quit.
Oh, the game won't let me save.
Ani!
Welcome to Ramboosham!
Thank you!
Kursum, thank you for the super diet.
Little- clowns.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm stuck inside the game.
Oh, someone else.
help me quit.
Oh, I don't know how to quit.
Oh, I just need to quit the game.
Oh, it's a really long scene.
Oh, we are following the dog.
Oh, the dog is crossing the street.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
New OG song preview.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, quitting the
game.
Oh, no, no, the game said.
Oh, no, no, no, you're not quitting the game.
Uh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
How much longer is it?
Oh, we're gonna Run and run, all through the town.
Spookiest freestyle ever.
At least we don't have stamina.
But Kaysen, keeping up is kind of impressive.
This is like one of my Japanese animas, man.
If you die in the game, you might die again in real life.
Someone in the song said, that's my jam, turn it up.
There's one save phone ahead if you're faster.
enough if i'm fast enough okay and so me though leaked her
new wait he can be a little selfish but he's a good dog he
stayed with me all this time through all the good and the
bad how long have you been together oh we go back a long
time i can't even remember a time when he wasn't so me
though leaked her new international super hit oh the game
won't let me quit live on stream being left alone and always
followed me around.
I could tell him anything, even things I couldn't tell my
parents.
He'd look into my eyes and listen intently to anything I had
to say.
It's like he sympathized and he didn't make fun of me.
Sometimes I wonder if my pet is...
My worries just faded away.
Glitcherous old man though.
Made me feel like I was just a fool for worrying so much.
Dogs are great that way.
Oh yeah, sometimes I think they got a lot more wisdom than
us humans even if they are betrayed well they don't see why
because i'm like changing in front of my cat and i'm like
you know dogs you better not be a old man i'm positive even
if man perishes off the face of the earth dogs why they'll
just carry on regardless they see everything you know from
their dog houses they look out and they see what humans do
kason can we continue We're wasting time deputy will he's
calling for us.
He's always like that.
Let's get back to the chase.
Yes, please Oh my god.
Oh
They won't let me out of the game.
Oh, they won't let me out of the game.
Oh, I can't quit the game Oh, I'm trying I want to go eat
dinner.
Oh, but
again.
Oh, is that?
it i'm trapped in a tube oh my god guys i think we're really
just never gonna be able to quit this oh thomas i know that
you're there your disposition is not of my concern but you
do need to stop this untie me let me go damn sas right now
sas afras are there and you and carol should take off go as
far away as you can open a bar or a diner in a new town with
your cooking I know you do well.
Why, thank you.
York, you're so kind.
Unlike him.
If I had someone like you, things may not have come to this.
Say your name.
Have you ever been in love with someone?
Thomas, a long time ago, I witnessed two people that I
really cared about die.
Both pretty much at the same time.
I've tried not to care about anyone so deeply, but recently
that way of thinking has changed Emily, right?
She's a nice girl.
But I must warn you, York.
Yeah?
You'd be better off not falling in love with her.
Why is it because she's going to die?
She's the next sacrifice.
Don't, don't do it!
Considering the circumstances, whatever I say might not be
important to you, but I'll say it anyways.
Don't you dare touch Emily.
York, I think I've said too much.
It's natural to respond when someone talks to you, I guess.
Everything will end tonight.
You just stay there until then.
York, your biscuit.
I mean, not York, Thomas, your biscuits.
Your biscuits.
Green tomato.
Sla-Thomas.
But actually don't.
Like...
Like actually...
Don't do that.
Oh my god.
Just wanna quit the game.
I just wanna quit the game.
I don't wanna chase the dog.
I want to quit the game.
I see the phone booth on the map.
I am going to run to the phone booth.
We're gonna quit the game.
They say oh, yes, yes, yes
Oh Well, isn't that very curious, huh?
This has been an absolute trip as As this game always is
this is It is...
So crazy.
It is so, so fun.
And I hope you guys are enjoying the ride as much as I am.
So, yeah, the next one is probably gonna be the finale.
That's really exciting!
Because I don't do literally anything...
Every...
Every time I never know what's gonna happen.
I didn't think I'd see...
You know, when we went into Thomas' apartment and it was the
sexy music playing, I didn't think we were actually gonna
see sexy Thomas.
And him probably giving like a lap dance and more to the
killer.
Super awesome.
Minto quit the game official song drum.
When?
It's a work in progress.
But I was just, I was just, you know, speaking my process,
speaking, you know, it into existence and all, you know.
I'm going to miss this fever dream of a game.
Honestly, V2!
I really am.
I know there's a second one.
I'm not quite sure if I'll play it yet or not.
It actually looks like garbage.
But, you know.
Thank you, Minto.
Loving the playthrough.
You're gonna have to catch the VOD as work, but can't wait.
Oh, thank you, Karsa!
Thank you!
Yeah.
Thank you for watching, even if it's the VOD.
Thanks to the pun and crazy stream, Minto.
Thank you!
I heard mixed things about the second one, sadly.
All I know is you can fight alligators.
But what?
Does anyone know what the second one came out on?
because it looks like it runs like a PSP game or something.
Thanks for the wild ride tonight.
Don't eat the poipo toy key.
Yeah, the second one does have a skateboard, yeah.
Wait, it's for the Switch.
It originally came out on this...
It looks so bad.
It's so laggy.
Wait, are we serious?
Switch exclusive.
I'm shocked.
I'm so shook it.
It looks like a PSP game.
But like...
Then I think of Peace Walker.
That game runs great.
But holy cow.
Wow.
There's a PC port.
Okay, okay.
It actually works on PC and runs at a better frame rate.
Again, I'm not sure if I'll play it yet.
But if we're...
more york morgan than maybe but yeah thank you guys for part
six of deadly premonition and we'll i'll see you hopefully
for the finale next time if you're into this wacky world the
game they made after this dark dreams don't die makes every
character like york i don't know if i can do that well i
never got past episode two it's still phenomenal i'm so
happy you've had fun with my jank this has been such a such
a ride i love it if you really couldn't quit the game it
would have been quite lame but thank you for that amazing
musical rotation we shall join you next time for more deadly
premonition may your dinner delight and may you have a super
relaxing and happy night so says mr stewart thank you for
the pink door go thank you thank you thank you guys so
good night have a good time zone and i will see you next
time enjoy your dinner you as well enjoy the rest of your
day thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank
you bye bye bye bye bye thank you thank you bye bye